something terrible happened here and for
decades people didn't talk about it I
was an adult before I ever heard about
it it was something that was was hidden
this entire historic community was
obliterated bodies dumped in rivers
bodies dumped in mass graves it was an
absolute massacre this story isn't one
you'll find in most history books and
almost a hundred years later the facts
of what exactly happened that day are
still unraveling
[Music]
so we're driving in what's known as
Black Wall Street it's where one of the
nation's worst episodes of racial
violence took place in 1921 a
neighborhood in Tulsa Oklahoma called
the Greenwood district was a bustling
community of black owned businesses
Tulsa locals know that period of
Greenwoods history as a kind of golden
age if you can imagine just a like an
old-time downtown things like movie
theaters pharmacies hair salons and so
forth they called it black Wall Street
it was a mecca it was a huge success but
black Wall Street was also an anomaly it
thrived at a time when the KKK was
incredibly active in Oklahoma and the
nation had just been through the red
summer of 1919 when white mobs murdered
black people in dozens of incidents
across the u.s. there needed to be a
sort of match or an igniter tossed on
these embers and that event was a
trigger event was an incident that
involved two teenagers dick Rowland 19
year old black boy shined shoes downtown
Sarah page 17 year-old white girl ran an
elevator in a downtown building called a
Drexel building he went to the building
boarded the elevator something happened
to Sarah Paige began to scream they both
ran out of the elevator now we don't
know exactly what happened in this
elevator but a day later Rowland was
arrested and taken to the courthouse the
local newspaper ran an article claiming
Roland had assaulted page even though
Paige refused to press charges
the article was essentially a call to
action for whites a large white mob
began to gather on the lawn of the
courthouse stick roll was in jail on the
top floor a number of black men several
dozen marched down to the courthouse to
protect him some of them armed there was
a struggle between one of the black man
and the small group and one
in larger group and things sort of went
south from from that point hundreds of
white people descended upon black Wall
Street armed black residents withdrew
behind the railroad tracks that marked
off the Greenwood district some of them
were armed and fought back but they were
outnumbered by the white mob which shot
their way through the white mob murdered
they looted and they set fire to black
Wall Street this was the strategy if you
will of how to deal with these
communities with these successful black
the effects were disastrous for two days
the Greenwood district burned martial
law was declared and the National Guard
was brought in by the time the massacre
ended Greenwood was in ruins more than
1,200 homes were destroyed and 35 blocks
burned the exact number of casualties is
harder to pin down some initially only
reported that white people died others
reported somewhere between 30 and 100
mostly black casualties but estimates
now put that number closer to 300 as for
those that survived thousands of them
lived in tent cities in the months that
followed and were left to pick up the
pieces of rubble they once called home
after the massacre the cover-up started
records went missing from city files
including the very article that started
it all it makes photos from this time
all the more important as part of the
historical record but back in 1921 these
images served a very different purpose
so photo postcards like these were
pretty widely distributed after the
massacre at the time they were a part of
white supremacist culture and kept as
souvenirs of racially charged crimes now
they're preserved to make sure this part
of Tulsa's history isn't forgotten and
they paint a clearer picture of how much
destruction there was that day on the
postcards
it's called vent also race riot a name
that itself
sort of erases what really happened by
calling it a riot it's a way of trying
to rewrite the history assuming that
there were both sides at fault and that
was not the case I'll call it a massacre
and I'll call it that because that's
what it was
Greenwood eventually rebuilt but nearly
a century later there's a part of this
story that still haunts the city no one
actually knows where the victims bodies
are we've got to find our people we've
got to put them at rest you know if not
we continue to be haunted by what was
done so many years ago cabin Ross a
local writer is one of many in Tulsa
descended from people who lost
everything in the massacre
so in this Cemetery there are only two
official victims of the Tulsa Reese
massacre how many victims do you think
there are
that's all these years I think 300 is
putting in mouth in 1997
the city finally put together a
commission to study the massacre and
help piece together what happened in
1921 they compiled records and
eyewitness accounts this is a house on
fire went right street to the curtains
is that the curtains on fire these
accounts are especially important now
because none of these survivors are
alive anymore and they also provided new
information some mentioned trucks like
this one loaded with victims of the riot
one right witness in particular came
forth testifying that he saw bodies
being dumped in Oakland Cemetery this is
it
this is the area using the survivor
accounts records and eventually radar
the city was able to pinpoint three
locations with anomalies in the soil
only one step was left to excavate but
it was something the city at the time
wasn't up for doing for many Tulsans it
was a part of history best forgotten and
not worth investigating
in some ways today that sentiment
remains waste of money it's over as that
one but there are clear signs of a city
that's ready to come to terms with a
dark chapter in its history honestly
that's a lot of missing people people
that probably had families we owe it to
the people who whose blood is actually
fertilized the grounds of this place
there was a tremendous amount of racism
injustice plus time does not equal
justice today a new mayor is reopening
the investigation I think a pretty basic
compact that a city makes with its
citizens is if somebody murders you we
will do everything we can to find out
what happened to you and give your
family closure
and whether that whether you were
murdered yesterday or you were murdered
98 years ago the city will be looking
into the three areas that the Commission
noted that process of finding out what
lies beneath Tulsa and DNA matching any
remains with descendants could take
years the investigation is just one part
of a bigger historical reckoning but the
reality is it can't undo the crimes or
the cover-up of the 1921 Tulsa race
Massacre this this story is the greatest
conspiracy of silence that I've ever
seen in history thanks for watching if
you haven't already heard we've launched
a paid membership program called the
video lab for a monthly fee subscribers
get access to tons of special features
becoming a member is the best way to
support our work so head on over to
voxcom slash join to sign up see you
there